thank you for staying so long and I'm
gonna be
about how we are embedding v8d
javascript engine v8 in the native
script project how's the muder it's
required
[Applause]
so before we start just to make sure
that we're on the same page we'll
explain a few basic terms first what is
the JavaScript engine so JavaScript
engine is a computer program that
executes J's code
thanks Wikipedia and also most modern
JavaScript engines utilize just-in-time
compilation and when I first read that a
few years back I was like wait you just
say compilation I taught it I was
writing in a language that's kind of
interpreted and not compiled and I was I
was reading through different blog post
doing some research trying to figure out
what is going on it's my whole life a
lie was a was a reading yeah so it turns
out that yeah javascript is interpreted
but it's not just that the first
JavaScript engine that was created was
just the interpreter but it turns out
that we started choosing jealously for a
lot of more things that it was initially
thought is gonna be used for so there
had to be some performance improvements
to the way the JavaScript engine works
so this is what actually the modern
JavaScript engine engines do and the
blog post that I got it from is the jasc
if starboard startup performance by eros
money you can find the link later but
the blog post says that this is actually
a simplification of what javascript
engine that's under the hood I was like
ok cool so why do we actually need that
and as I mentioned before well
performance that's it
so the first just-in-time compiler and
very Tina
script engine was trace monkey which is
actually part of the spider monkey
JavaScript engine which was owned by a
Mozilla and it was back in 2007 or
something like that a little bit after
that v8 was released and that was the
same time when chrome was released and
this really boosted the performance of
JavaScript in the browser and everywhere
else
and that kind of explains how the whole
JavaScript engine development happened
and why is it I mean we started from
just some interpreters and this is what
we've got now so if you want to read the
proper explanation of what JIT compiler
is I really recommend this blog post by
link work was here today just two hours
before and yeah really excited to be on
the same stage anyway and another great
great resource is the talk life of a
script which is really recent and it's
by Satya and Yaqoob from the VA team and
they're explaining all the optimizations
that the v8 engine does under the hood
in order to make JavaScript faster let's
move on
I'm already mentioned that I'm going to
be talking about v8 it is a JavaScript
engine it is built at Google for Chrome
and it was open sourced in 2008 and here
I have this really cool video that you
can check out later is by Wars back who
was the first tech lead for the v8
project and what he said in that video
is that v8 is not just something that
chrome uses underneath you can actually
take v8 as a standalone project and
embed it at different place and this
kind of worked out well because node.js
embedded v8 and this is how we get
JavaScript on the server and what we're
trying to do in projects like native
script is actually bring JavaScript the
mobile world as well
so native script a few words about me I
am developer it's progress
part of the native script team and so
recently I became a GD for angular and
12 technologies are important thing
about me is that I love web pack I do
quite a lot of web pack things in native
script and this is I'm sure this is a
wipeout carrier but as you can see I'm
smiling because you have to accept these
things all right back on native script I
want a real story I read a short story
and I know I mean it's kind of weird but
I kind of had a long flight and then I
actually wrote that story and then I
could it's like 8% of it because it gets
even more weird so that's just an
explanation why why why it's like that
anyway
so we have the JavaScript world and we
have these great magical creatures
living in the JavaScript world not
really technology technologically
advanced but they know a lot of spells
and they're kind of like elves but not
like the Santa Claus
kind of type but more like deals from
worth of the Rings like magical handsome
awesome creatures and so I don't think
about the elves is that they're pretty
expansive as a nation or tribe and they
kinda expanded the browser world but
here's the zero difference we shouldn't
mix the terms browser and JavaScript
because they are not interchangeable
they're chinks in the browser which are
not part of the JavaScript language
obviously the most obvious difference is
the DOM and HTML
of course the someone say CSS
we're gonna come back back to CSS later
anyway another important world in our
story is the Android world and the
androids world obviously is populated by
robots which have really great
technological knowledge and they have a
lot of native resources and native
resource what is it
so satellites geolocation Bluetooth
camera augmented reality kids she
warning kids basically everything you
have on your phone today the Android
people take it for granted and they have
access to it so I'm doing a really but
metaphor generate world use your mobile
phone anyway so what is the deal the
folks from the JavaScript world the
elves are pretty expansive and they want
to use the native resources from the
Android world but they're not great
diplomats I mean it's probably the whole
Java JavaScript think anyway there is
not a really easy way to use native
resources from the Android world from
JavaScript and this is the problem that
we're trying to solve in native script
and if I say we it's kind of weird
because yet neither script has been part
of my life for three years and a if I
say we I mean the name script team and I
know this is the same slide what I was
too lazy to change it okay so shortly
native script is a framework that allows
you to build native mobile apps for
Android and iOS with JavaScript or
something a bit more sophisticated like
your angular really short overview of
the architecture obviously we have
Android and iOS on the bottom we have
may skip runtimes which allow us to have
access to the native resources from
JavaScript don't top that we have a
common layer which unifies the end
in the i/os api's so for example you've
ever had to build user interface on
android and user interface on iOS you
would have realized that they're quite
different so we provide a common
layouting structure or system that
allows you to write the same code and it
should kind of work the same way on both
Android and iOS on top of that we have a
really really small layer for the
application flavor framework which gives
you data bindings and navigation and we
also support angular and view and the
last important bit is that if there is
some library out there in the Android
world you can just wrap that as a notes
package ship it to NPM and anyone can
npm install your package and use it in
your native script app but today we're
going to be focusing on the name Swift
runtimes
and how we access the native resources
and more specifically we're going to
focus on the Android runtime because
this is where we embed v8 for iOS we
actually embed another JavaScript engine
JavaScript core which is used in Safari
so native API access important thing
about the elves they're not just like
not advanced in technology they also
don't have great scientific knowledge
but that's fine so even if they had
access to the native resources they
wouldn't really know how to use them so
what they do in that case is that they
send out some spice in the Android world
and these PI's gather information about
the native resources so they go back to
the JavaScript world with that
information and now the elves know how
to use the native resources but they
have to get there so we're still not
quite there but they know how to use the
resources
how does that look like in more boring
way so we have a native library for
example Android SDK or some animation
library in Android we parse through the
whole library to generate metadata
basically we get every package every API
did that's available and gathering
information how we can use it so if
there is some method we should know what
how many arguments the method accepts
what are their types what is the return
type so we gather all that information
and package that inside the application
itself in some binary format and the
application package itself is not very
different from a regular Android
application so we have just the Android
application inside it we have the
JavaScript code as some assets and 20q
the JavaScript code we also have a
library which contains the native
scripts runtime and v8 which is the
engine that can execute JavaScript we
run the application the Weibull restarts
we initialize v8 then we set up some
callbacks that we're going to take a
look at right the next slide and then we
launch the regular Android activity and
we have a normal Android up running so
Kovaks
very important if you are ever gonna
embed v8 callbacks or everywhere
first we have a field get a callback so
con stop jack Tico's java.lang object is
actually a valid JavaScript code in
native script Java comes from something
that we set on the v8 instance as a
global object because it was inside the
metadata so we know that we can access
the Java
or Java because it's available in the
Android world java.lang is actually
where the field Gator Quebec is attached
so whenever someone calls java.lang from
the JavaScript world we trigger that
field get her callback and the Quebec
finds the metadata inside the java.lang
package and returns what is exactly
there in that package what we can what
we can use
and finally Java rank object just
returns the object class from the
java.lang metadata kind of constructor
Quebec okay whenever we try to create
the new instance of something in the
Android world we trigger a constructor
callback which was placed there by the
name super on time so the constructor
Quebec creates the objects in generate
world and it also creates a proxy object
in the JavaScript world and then returns
the proxy object the method Quebec
okay so what is special about the proxy
javascript object for example if we have
two methods in the Java object and we're
going to have exactly the same methods
in the JavaScript object and in these
methods we attach a method call back so
whenever someone calls that method on
the JavaScript object it's going to
trigger that Quebec in the Quebec is
actually gonna called the original Java
method and after it's caught we're going
to get some results and we're gonna pass
it back and this is a more of an
implementation detail but we can't
actually just pass back the return
result to the JavaScript function but we
have to set the result as a return
argument of that proxy function or
method okay so so far we know that we
have metadata but it is exactly
it's actually not enough to have
metadata in order to call stuff on the
native Android world so we're using
something called j'ni or Java native
interface and because currently we
started v8 this one virtual machine we
also have the dalvik virtual machine
running on the Android device J&I is the
thing that passes all calls from the
JavaScript virtual machine down to the
Java Virtual Machine and the same way
back this is the actual bridge if you
ever heard of a bridge inside of native
script okay but there's a little
complication here what happens if the
Java object the Java method returns a
string
well the shrink is gonna be of type Java
long string which is definitely not the
same as a JavaScript string or a string
object or even a string a string
primitive they're just two different
data formats that's why we need some
kind of marshaling service that can
convert data from the Java world to the
JavaScript world and vice versa and
maybe you'd ask if you think more about
it what about objects I mean wouldn't it
be terribly slow if we start converting
objects from the Java world back to
JavaScript well I should this is why we
create proxies this and of course
attaching method call backs so we use
smush ring for primitives and arrays and
obviously the marshaling service and
j'ni are c-3po in our already weird
story because c-3po is a protocol droid
so it translates messages back and forth
and yeah really proud of that comparison
so let's see very quickly how that works
we're trying to instantiate a new native
object we call the constructor callback
this requests an instance of the class
from the Android virtual machine we get
back the instance of the class we return
which way the JavaScript proxy object
and return it back then we try to call
some method we come Kody method callback
that was attached on the proxy object
then through the method callback we call
the actual native method we get back the
result from the Java world and then
convert it to a JavaScript data format
and assign it to the variable so far so
good okay we're ready for I have no idea
how much time I have it's just getting
interesting
cool let's talk about multi-threading in
JavaScript weird cool I will try to
explain the term junk or there are a lot
of ways to code that behavior but here's
the thing most of the devices that we're
using nowadays have to draw something 60
times per second on the screen so this
is what we call a frame rate the frame
rate of a usual device nowadays is 60
frames per second and that means that we
basically have 16 milliseconds to draw a
single frame on the device and that
means that whatever computations we are
doing right now we have to finish in 16
milliseconds and be ready to draw
something on the screen
and of course 60 milliseconds is the
upper bound because there may be other
computations happening and this may be
actually down to 10 milliseconds in the
browser which is not a lot of time and
so what happens if we fail to meet that
10 milliseconds well we drop a frame or
we skip a frame
and when we start skipping frames where
things start to happen and this is the
term junk I'm gonna put that on a really
slow motion so that we can see the
actual animation cool awesome so here we
have a really smooth animation running
in 60 frames per second focus on D I
just realized this is a beard
I told it's a scarf anyway yeah so focus
on the beards 60 frames per seconds
looks pretty cool here it kind of keeps
a few frames right 15 frames per second
you can definitely see the difference
between this animation and this
animation so this is called junk and
it's very obvious when you start
scrolling and the list just steps or
lags cool why is that important well we
run the JavaScript in native script on a
single thread and that is obviously the
user interface thread so that might
cause junk in some cases it won't cause
jank
if you're using native script the right
way no if you're building user interface
you won't have any problem because
native script is using native components
underneath if you're building animations
that won't be a problem because
underneath we're using native animations
and so on and so on but it will cause
gen if you're executing CPU intensive
operations for example if you're trying
to calculate Fibonacci numbers in a very
an optimized way which is something we
do in our everyday lives
perfect example so this would cause Jan
because it will stress the main trait
and the matron won't be able to to put
out
you know 60 frames per second so how do
we solve that problem in JavaScript
well the browser has web workers and in
native script we call them worker
threads but basically they're just
background threads or separate threads
than the user interface thread in the
JavaScript world okay the deal with the
worker threads is that you can create
them they can do some computations in
the background and then they can return
some result that's the whole the whole
thing the downsides in a new script is
that you can't share JavaScript memory
you can actually share native objects
and also the communication is limited so
you it's not a great idea to return
really large objects or recursive
objects also can't be returned okay some
VA time the really interesting thing
what is the nice relate to v8 well this
is a running instance of the engine and
is actually a v8 way to allocate memory
for some script that's running and
isolate that memory so it can't be
accessed from other processes and also
you can have many isolates and they can
run in parallel another similar term or
related term is a context one isolate
can have multiple contexts the context
can run in parallel so basically when
when you're running a script in an
isolate you should explicitly specify
the the context what is the constant
context right now so how do you think we
implemented worker threads with isolates
or with context isolates contexts we
didn't implement
okay well the answer is isolate and
everyone raised their hint was no one
guessed right cool so worker traits are
isolates basically you create a new
instance of v8 you attach some callbacks
or that G to isolate can communicate and
that's how we have worker threads and
the way they work in browsers is pretty
similar okay
lasting snapshots let's talk about time
and I don't mean that I'm running out of
time although that's true but what takes
time in a mobile applications and more
specifically what takes time on startup
well obviously on the mobile device we
don't have Network requests all the
scripts that we're running when we're
starting the applications are already on
the device but we have to get them from
the file system so that takes time if
there are many files also parsing and
compiling JavaScript takes time because
JavaScript engines and how do we solve
the problem they actually these two
things can take quite a lot of time and
this is a screenshot from two years ago
and at the time that was how much it
took to start an a script application in
a very an optimized way of course and
two seconds just to load the JavaScript
up the app it's kind of weird so how do
we solve that problem first we can
borrow our app so we can use a tool like
web pack to get all of our millions of
files in our application and output a
few files for example - so that way we
won't be making millions of file
requests on startup we were making just
two file requests
person compiled obviously we can skip
that part we just have to isolate our
JavaScript code somehow but there is
this trick which is called custom
startup snapshots which is a really
great feature provided by the v8 engine
and I'm not sure if it's the only one
but it's definitely not provided by JSC
that's why we have it only on Android so
the way it works is that you take a
JavaScript file you run it through some
generation tool that outputs that
executes the code and then you take
basically a snapshot of the heap at the
current time and output that in some
binary file and the binary file gets in
your file pack in your application
package and when you start the app you
load the snapshot binary you set some
parameters for the isolates passing
these snapshots binary and then when you
create the new isolate you can basically
instruct it to create the new context
from the already loaded heap so it
doesn't have to load the JavaScript from
the filesystem
compile it parse it whatever it does
underneath and it basically takes these
two seconds to zero and this is a little
bit of code and if you're interested and
not it's not going to read it obviously
because I don't have time but you can
find it in the slides later I'm going to
share them and this section is C++ code
but the idea of the that code here was
that it's not that hard to get a grasp
of how you can embed v8 it's it's free
actually understandable API okay what
are the limitations of the snapshots
basically we are executing the code at
Build time so we don't have any access
to the native funds rate or whatever API
is also we don't have require and I
don't have time to explain that but
finally later I can talk to you about
require where does it
from and why it's not a JavaScript
Tinky actually anyway also third-party
codes can break the snapshots because
we're not sure if the third-party code
is now trying to access something which
is not available at Build time so how
can we solve that first we can wrap
native API access here obviously we're
trying to access new Android text format
time and if we execute that in a better
context without metadata without j'ni we
don't have hundred so this is going to
throw an error the way to fix that is
just to wrap that in a getter function
and you get the time lazily inside the
other function that does some
complicated things does the audio and if
you're really lazy I don't have time to
explain that code but you can create
getters like that I'm gonna give you
just a few seconds to wrap your hand
around the first thing it's a very
interesting function yeah I still don't
get it anyway so it is that you have to
be lazy when trying to access in 85
years and just really quick reference
the editor item is using snapshots to
optimize their startup time as well and
they have a great blog post on how they
used keep snapshots to to do that and
garbage collection and obviously if I
start talking about garbage collection
right now we can just flow into the next
day and if you're interesting in how
we're trying to synchronize to garbage
collectors the v8s one and Avex one you
can check out this blog post it's a very
interesting problem and that was it
thank you
you